is it worth me dying for this  about how many dollars do you think this  is worth  thousands i would say the cost of these  drug regimens today is 40 to 50 000  per person per year drug companies are  in the business of treating diseases not  necessarily curing diseases it kind of  freaks people out that you're just  playing with your body this way a new  person is infected every 15 minutes the  more time we waste the more lives that  we are losing people's lives are not  commodities i don't know what it all  means anymore i don't between the chills  and the fever and throwing up and  everything else  just keep saying what have i done  my commitment to this trial it yeah it's  worth it is worth dying for